MANVINDER SINGH:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars with Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Manvinder Singh.
I'm part of the
Google Cloud team.
And with me is Alim
Karim from NetApp.
And we're going to be
talking about NetApp Cloud
Volumes for GCP, a
new storage service
that you can use with
your GCP workloads.
So before we get
started, just a reminder,
you can ask questions
at any point of time.
Just use the platform.
And we have
colleagues standing by
to help you answer
those questions.
All right, so let's get started.
Some of you may have
seen last month,
we announced our strategic
partnership with NetApp.
And we announced that we're
collaborating to launch
NetApp Cloud Volumes for GCP.
This is a new storage service.
It's a high-performance service
that offers multiple protocols.
It offers NFS, SMB.
And if you use GCP
for your workloads,
you can use their
storage service
while taking advantage of
various advanced management
features like data
synchronization, and snapshots,
and cloning with your workloads.
And in today's session,
we'll talk more about
what this service is, when to
use it, what kind of use case
is, and how to use
the service, as well.
So just to talk quickly
about the agenda,
we'll start by
talking about when
to use NetApp Cloud Volumes.
We'll talk about
the architecture,
and what kind of use cases you
can use this for, and also talk
about when it's going to be
available in which regions,
and so forth.
And then finally, we'll
end with live Q and A.
With that said,
let's get started.
Alim, talk to us
about when can we
use Cloud Volumes,
what kind of use cases.
ALIM KARIM: Yeah.
So we initially, before
we designed and developed
Cloud Volumes, we spent a lot
of time talking to customers,
and really understanding
the context of file
and unstructured workloads as
it related to public cloud.
And when we looked at the data
after all of that analysis,
we found that you could
group these problems
into three main areas--
and three main areas
and three main personas.
So first, as the
slide shows, is you
have a set of application owners
and application administrators
that are trying to migrate
existing applications
from on-premise to the cloud.
And these applications are built
around requiring POSIX file
services.
And it's very difficult
to re-architect them,
so the easiest way is usually
to take them as they are,
with minimal re-architecture,
and move them to the cloud.
And the reasons
behind these vary.
Perhaps the customer is moving
out of a physical data center.
Perhaps they're trying to
map the application that
has a variable business
process, and they
want to take advantage of
the elasticity of the cloud
to do it.
So the use case is actually
vary behind the [? why ?]
on the migrate side.
The second is a set of
developers and DevOps folks
that are trying to build new
applications in the cloud that
require shared file semantics.
And a quick example
of this, as you know,
you're trying to
set up a Kubernetes
cluster that could have
thousands of containers in it.
And all of those
containers require access
to a shared file system.
So that's another big use
case that we're seeing.
And then finally, we have
data analysts, data engineers,
that have a lot of
unstructured data on premise
that they want to
take to Google Cloud
to take advantage of
the advanced machine
learning and
analytics capabilities
that the Cloud offer, to
be able to get value out
of that unstructured data.
So those are the
three broad use cases.
Now, common amongst these use
cases on the right-hand side
is really the expectation.
So all of these personas really
have three main expectations
around any service that
satisfies these problems.
The first is this
notion of experience.
And experience is not just about
performance and scalability.
It's also about how well
the service is really
integrated into GCP,
and integrated not
just from control plane, but
also from a support and billing
perspective.
The other two pieces
are on consumption
and economics really
go hand in hand.
So being a true cloud
service, customers
expect this to be able to
ramp up their consumption.
And the economics of that
go up with consumption.
And as the consumption
comes down,
their economics goes down.
And then the final piece is,
within any cloud context,
the ability to have a
high degree of security
and compliance as
part of the service.
So now let's talk
about Cloud Volumes
for Google, what they are,
and the various elements
that go with them.
So the simplest way to
think about Cloud Volumes
is that they are a
no-ops managed service.
They offer our customers a
simple-to-consume performant
NFS or SMB endpoint.
And all the customer has to
do is consume that endpoint,
without having to worry about
any of the infrastructure
pieces that are behind the
scenes to operate that.
That's between NetApp and
Google to handle that.
So there's really no need to
manage, patch, scale, maintain,
do any of the
infrastructure-related tasks.
There's three different
service levels
that we offer cloud volumes on.
And the next slide will go
into some of those details.
But each of those
service levels is really
just a simple NFS or SMB
endpoint in a no-ops fashion.
The second element is really
around native user experience.
So when customers go
and provision, manage,
and monitor cloud
volumes, they actually
get an interface,
a user interface
that is identical to
how they would provision
any other Google service.
MANVINDER SINGH: So I just
want to stress upon that point,
because when customers use
partner services on GCP,
they're not used to actually
using the same interface.
So this would look and feel
just like a Google service?
ALIM KARIM: Exactly.
And really what we
wanted to focus on here
is keeping that customer
experience seamless,
keeping them within
the Google ecosystem.
And therefore, they don't have
to learn other interfaces,
and just use what
they're used to.
The next point around rich
data management-- this
is where NetApp brings
its years of capabilities
around being able to rapidly
create snapshots, clones,
and be able to synchronize
data for all of the data that
lives in Cloud Volumes.
Support is another area that
we hear from customers about,
in that to complete
that customer lifecycle,
the ability to have integrated
support is very, very
important.
So with Cloud
Volumes, L1 support
is actually managed by
the Google Cloud team,
with similar SLOs as
other GCP services.
On the right-hand side, around
pay-as-you-go and billing--
so again, being a
cloud service, you only
pay for the amount of
capacity you provision.
And that provision
capacity can vary over
the course of a day, over
the course of a week,
over the course of a month.
And you just pay for
the average consumption
over the course of a month.
With that is the notion
of integrated billing.
So even though this
is a NetApp service,
it's very deeply
integrated with Google.
So you as a customer get
your bill from Google,
just as part of your
regular GCP invoice,
with the consumption of Cloud
Volumes as a single line
item on that bill.
Hybrid enabled-- I talked
a lot about customers
being able to move data between
on-premise and the cloud.
So we're offering services
to be able to sync data
from on-prem, making it
easier for customers to move
to Cloud Volumes in GCP.
And then finally, we
have a plan to roll out
this service across
the globe, starting
with some regions in the US,
and expanding out as we go.
MANVINDER SINGH: So all these
points taken together, Alim--
with the native user experience,
with integrated support,
with billing being
integrated-- as a user,
I may not even have
to talk to NetApp
or interface with NetApp
while consuming the service.
Right?
ALIM KARIM: Absolutely.
Right.
And this is, again,
to the earlier point
that we were making
is we want customers
to stay within
the GCP ecosystem,
and reduce the friction that it
takes to consume this service.
MANVINDER SINGH: Cool.
ALIM KARIM: Now lets
talk about service level.
So cloud volumes are
really available in,
let's call it three
different flavors.
And these flavors are identical,
in the sense that you can offer
or you can consume both
NFS and SMB protocols
across any service level.
You get the advanced
data management features
across all service
levels, and the ability
to take snapshots,
do rapid copies,
do cloning, or do
data synchronization.
But what's different
with these service
levels is the
amount of throughput
that you get per terabyte of
capacity that you provision.
So we have standard.
We have premium.
We have extreme.
Standard offers
customers 16 megabytes
per terabyte provision.
Premium is 64
megabytes per terabyte.
And then extreme is double that,
at 128 megabytes per terabyte.
There are three
different price points
to go along with these three
different service levels.
And really, why we have
these three flavors,
as the use cases
indicate, we intend
customers to be able to
use different service
levels for different
kinds of workloads.
So in the case of
standard, they're
likely going to use things like
file backup or web serving.
In the case of
premium, they're going
to use it for virtualized
applications, potentially
general-purpose databases.
And then on the
extreme side, really,
is where use cases like
high-performance computing
and OLTP come into play.
MANVINDER SINGH: On
high-performance computing,
that can be so many different
use cases across protocols.
There's EDA.
There's financial-- we
have a lot of hedge funds
who want to do Monte Carlo
simulations, for example,
and want NFS endpoints
to store the data.
There's genomic sequencing.
Is that-- all of those
use cases, do they
fit into the extreme tier?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, exactly.
Because those are
all-- typically,
you find areas that
require high throughput,
sometimes high number of IOPS,
and very, very low latency.
So those are good fits
for the extreme tier.
MANVINDER SINGH: And
if I start with extreme
care, and I see that the
performance is already
very good for my use case, and I
may want a lower-priced option,
can I move to the Premium Tier?
ALIM KARIM: That's right.
You can dynamically move
to the Premium Tier.
MANVINDER SINGH: Awesome.
ALIM KARIM: So let's
say you're a customer,
and you want to consume
the Cloud Volume service.
So what does the technical
architecture underneath it
look like?
So here we have a
simple diagram that
shows a standard Google customer
project on the left-hand side.
In this project, we
have GCE instances
that have been provisioned
in the us-east4 region.
Note that these instances could
be in any zone in us-east4.
And they're in
within a given VPC.
On the right-hand side is
where you have the Cloud Volume
Service.
And in this case, the user
has used that interface
to provision three
cloud volumes.
So on the top part, you'll
notice a dotted line,
and so there's a subscription
element between the customer's
project and the
cloud volume surface,
because each cloud
volume only exists
within the context
of a Google project,
just like any other Google
resource within a project.
On the bottom part
for each cloud volume,
we expose an export path, which
is then used by the instances
to mount that volume, and
access the data in that volume.
A few things to note here--
cloud volumes in this case
are accessible to any instance
in any zone within
a given region.
That's number one.
Number two is with the
use of export policies,
you can really
actually restrict which
instances are able to see
the data in cloud volumes.
You can restrict it by a single
IP address for a single client.
You can restrict
it to an IP range.
And you can even tune
your export policies
so that you can allow certain
clients to read and write,
while other clients can only
read data in cloud volumes.
Now let's talk through
a few use cases,
and what we've seen with
early customers that
are using cloud volumes.
So the first one is around
continuous integration
and a software
development environment.
We have a customer who has an
automated CI environment that
essentially deploys a
cluster with over 1,000
different containers that
come up in that cluster.
And all of those containers
require access to a shared file
system to hold all the binaries
that the containers are going
to use for their build
jobs, as well as the output
to build artifacts once
the jobs are complete--
so again, a great use case
for Cloud Volumes, because you
get that shared file service.
But the other key
thing to note here
is the KPIs in this environment
are the amount of unit tests
that these customers
can do in a given hour.
And that is directly correlated
with the amount of time
it takes to do a build.
So it's not just about being
able to provide a shared file
system, but being able to
provide a shared file system
that is high performance.
So they need high
throughput, they
need low latency to be able
to keep those build times
to the minimum and do more
unit tests within a given
period of time.
The next use cases are
on video rendering.
And this is one of
those classic use
cases with media processing
workflows, rendering,
transcoding, both from a
production and post-production
sense, that have tools that
are built around shared file
system.
And the access pattern
here, it's actually
very different from the earlier
use case we talked about.
Here, access is very serial.
It is still high performance,
but it requires also,
again, very, very low latency.
This is another good use case
we see for Cloud Volumes that
matches the tools that
are built for this use
case with the performance
that Cloud Volumes deliver.
So earlier,
Manvinder, you touched
on high-performance
computing and EDA.
So I'm going to use
the EDA example here.
And EDA is a complicated
environment on its own.
You have various phases around
specification, block design
and verification, synthesis,
formal verification,
and simulation.
And each of these phases
has different tools
and requires different
file access patterns.
But this is an
example of workloads
that have, for years,
relied on file services.
So you have
applications and tools
that are designed with the
need for file services.
And these tools--
MANVINDER SINGH: And
especially protocols like NFS.
ALIM KARIM: Exactly.
And these tools are not
going to get re-architected.
They are going to
exist as they are.
It's just too hard to
rebuild these tools.
And so when you have front-end
design systems in this EDA
space that resemble
software R&D--
they're code heavy, they
use Verilog, they use VHDL.
And to your point,
these are tools
that, again, are very
tightly integrated with,
or require NFS.
And the KPI around here, again,
performance is of the essence--
the ability to complete
these workflows in time.
So this requires Cloud
Volumes specifically
to be able to handle large
volumes of small files
at very, very low
latency, especially
during the verification stage.
And the final use
cases are on databases.
And we have customers that
are using MySQL databases.
And this could be
other databases as well
for transactional web platforms.
And they are built-in
applications that actually
require scale-up performance.
But the other unique
thing around this,
or not just around
performance, is this customer
or this set of
customers actually
needs the ability to take
consistent point-in-time
reference copies off their
database for recovery purposes.
And again, the ability
to do this while
not impacting user experience,
still providing those high IOPS
and low latency on
a shared file system
are key for this
particular customer,
so another great use
case for Cloud Volumes.
MANVINDER SINGH: Awesome.
That's a lot of use cases.
ALIM KARIM: So let's talk about
timelines, where we are today,
and where we're going to go with
Cloud Volumes in the future.
So currently, the service is
available in private preview.
We've been running the private
preview since early May,
since about when we
announced the partnership.
MANVINDER SINGH: And
we have a few customers
that are trying Cloud Volumes,
and are really happy with it.
ALIM KARIM: That's right.
And we were offering this out
of the GCP us-east4 region.
For those of you
that are watching,
and are interested in
participating in the preview
and expressing your
interest for Cloud Volumes,
please go to the link
that's on the slide,
netapp.com/gcppreview,
and register there.
In terms of future, the
next phases for the service
are really taking it to
controlled availability
and general availability.
We're going to be making some
announcements around the Google
Next time frame, as well
as discussing which regions
the service rolls out to.
So I encourage
all of you, please
visit us at the
NetApp booth at NEXT.
Connect with our SMEs and
get some hands-on demos
at the booth, as well.
So to quickly
summarize, Cloud Volumes
for GCP basically are
simple to consume,
no-ops NFS or SMB services.
They offer our customers
high performance
and rich-data
management features,
and are very tightly
integrated into GCP
along different dimensions on
the user interface and control
plane side, with support,
and with billing.
And ultimately, Cloud
Volumes through Google
allow our customers to migrate
existing workloads to GCP,
allow our customers to
develop new applications
on GCP that require
performant file storage,
and finally, allow our
customers to take advantage
of the best-in-class
analytics and machine
learning capabilities
that Google
offers on unstructured data.
MANVINDER SINGH: Awesome.
Thank you, Alim.
All right, folks.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
MANVINDER SINGH: OK, so we've
got some great questions here.
I'm going to go a
little bit out of water,
Alim, just to touch upon the
stuff you just talked about.
So we talked about how a lot
of the features that customers
are used to on-premise,
with NetApp in many cases,
are now available in the cloud.
But the question that we're
getting a lot from our audience
is, how do I get that
data into cloud volumes?
I may have it in NetApp
on a different platform
How do I move that data?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah,
so we're actually
going to use our Cloud Sync tool
to be able to allow customers
to move data from on-premise
into Cloud Volumes,
as well as between
Cloud Volumes.
And we can expect that.
It's not available now.
But it will be a roadmap item
that we add around the GA time
frame.
MANVINDER SINGH: And that's
moving data over the network,
right?
ALIM KARIM: That's correct.
That's over the wire.
MANVINDER SINGH: And it doesn't
have to be NetApp on premise.
It can be--
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, and
this is the great thing
about a tool like Cloud Sync.
It can work with any
unstructured file format.
It could be NetApp storage.
It could be other storage.
Basically, as long as that
storage exposes an NFS endpoint
or SMB endpoint, we're
able to then migrate
that data into Cloud Volumes.
MANVINDER SINGH: And
any limit on the amount
of data I want to
move-- terabytes,
hundreds of terabytes?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah, so this
is where, again, it's
a use case-dependent question.
If you have small amounts of
data and you have good network
throughput, you're
able to move that,
using tools at Cloud Sync,
what we call "over-the-wire
synchronization tools."
But as you get into
larger, bulk data sets,
we're actually exploring
partnering with Google
on being able to move bulk
data in an offline fashion, so
more of a bulk data move,
and then followed by a sync
to get basically
hundreds of terabytes
into GCP, into Cloud Volumes.
MANVINDER SINGH:
OK, cool, awesome.
So talking about the
protocols that the service
is going to support, NFS, there
are multiple versions, V3, V4.
What's the thinking
on that front?
ALIM KARIM: So
initially, we're going
to support NFS V3 and SMB V3.
And I think that kind of answers
a couple of those questions.
We're going to add NFS
V4 support down the road.
And this is also an
area where we really
want to hear from our customers
on and what kind of protocols
they want to use.
We're hearing a lot of demand
for SMB V3 and NFS V3, which
is why we're starting htere.
MANVINDER SINGH:
That's where both
of the applications
[INTERPOSING VOICES] use,
right?
ALIM KARIM: Yeah.
I think based on some of the
analysis we did, about 80%
of the workloads that
are NFS based use NFS V3,
so that seemed like a
logical place to go.
But again, we're
open to feedback,
and hearing from customers on
use cases around interfaces V4,
and what they want to do.
MANVINDER SINGH: Great.
Fantastic.
Is a cloud volume accessible
from multiple GCP projects?
ALIM KARIM: So we
touched a little bit
on this presentation, but this
is a good question to bring up.
So much like any other GCP
resource within a project,
this is a
project-level resource.
So a cloud volume
exists and is accessible
only within the
context of a project.
So if you have
multiple projects,
Cloud Volume in
one project is only
accessible to that project.
Cloud Volumes in
another project is
only accessible to
that other project.
There is no sharing of Cloud
Volumes between projects.
MANVINDER SINGH: OK.
What regions is the
service available in?
ALIM KARIM: So
region-wise, we're
currently offering private
preview in us-east4.
However, we're going to be
rolling out to other regions
in the US.
The timeline for
that is when we will
talk about during the next
announcements in terms of which
regions are coming up and when.
MANVINDER SINGH:
One of the things
I want to add to that is, if
you have workloads that you want
to move to GCP, and you have
specific regions in mind,
please do give us the feedback.
You can use the link that we
shared earlier for signing up
for the private preview.
And that way, we'll
connect with you.
And we'd love to hear which
regions are a priority for you,
so we can work on those and
prioritize those accordingly.
Thank you for
tuning in, everyone.
That's all we had
for this session.
Please do stay tuned in
for the next session, which
is on connected
health care, and how
to enable secure entry points
into the cloud with Chrome.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]